we all want to make money you have it
you spend it a dollar on tutoring me of
course I go about to change to change
I'm over the top sometimes okay pretty
good I got with someone in this degree
check the road
I got a huge critical like this beauty
oh right now we're going to check our
most expensive dish [ __ ]
you can spend fifty sixty seventy eight
hundred thousand more more than you'd
imagine this year's broke up from lips
you know much probably you can get all
that plus the wires you can get the
wires anyway you will not work it's not
wireless the most expensive toothbrush
here are you sure you know how to brush
your teeth just want to show you the
jewel suite we're off the hook so I have
to pay for the pool oh you got a family
here yeah this is the Guinness World
Record most expensive burger will gold
on that you can eat go you can eat gold
seriously how much is that three hundred
and forty five thousand dollars or six
chains this is something I would like to
experience at least one time on Leiter's
nobody's readiness this expanse it's not
only the most expensive it's the best
given a bid